millions dead in a war with china a
disturbing
and dark prediction reveals the mass
devastation that could result from such
a scenario
the director of the australia china
relations institute at uts
james lawrenceson estimated we'd see
millions dead in such a conflict plus a
global economic disaster but it's not
like anyone's preparing for such a war
right
newly appointed australian defense
minister peter dutton
used anzac day australia's national day
of remembrance for some
good old-fashioned fear-mongering
against china
china is militarizing ports across our
region we need to
deal with all of that and that's exactly
what we're now focused on
but what's more troubling is that dutton
said that a conflict with china
could not be ruled out the prospects of
a battle over taiwan
are growing could happen quite soon do
you share that view
i don't think it should be discounted i
think and the australian home affairs
secretary mike possulo
delivered a message that expanded on
that the home affairs secretary has
warned
drums of war are beating as australian
tensions with china deepen further
when one of australia's most powerful
national security figures
says the drums of war are beating what
exactly does he really mean
he also warned we must prepare to send
off troops
yet again to fight whoa
danger danger danger first of all how
does australia plan on fighting
china australia's military budget is
around 40 billion dollars while
china's is 250 billion dollars australia
has
just under 60 000 active personnel on
duty while china has around 2.3 million
australia has around 450 military
aircraft
china has around 3 000. australia has
59 tanks china has 3 500.
australia's got 3 000 armored vehicles
china has 33 000
not to mention australia doesn't have
any nuclear weapons china has around 300
so a war with china would likely not end
great for australia meaning australia
would have to drag
others in with it and that could lead to
a global conflict that's probably why
china reacted to australia's threats
a bit more reasonably we hope the
australian side will fully recognize the
high sensitivity
of the taiwan issue the foreign ministry
declared
and what is the taiwan issue the root of
the conflict goes back to the early 20th
century when today's people's republic
of china was called the republic of
china
ruled by a nationalist government that
was eventually overthrown by the
communist party
in 1949 the nationalist government fled
to the island of taiwan
and ever since then the two governments
have been at odds over the status of the
island
with tensions flaring up from time to
time it is a complex issue
but the last thing this region needs is
some clumsy politicians from australia
or anywhere else
making threats that can severely
escalate tensions and
open the possibility of mass suffering
and destruction
take it easy australia